our series changing the game profiles
extraordinary women who are making a
difference now and for the future
Generations this morning we're speaking
with one business owner who is changing
what women wear when they give birth
Caitlin schullmeyer she's a labor and
delivery nurse and a doula she never
cared for the use of hospital gowns in
childbirth so she decided to design her
own gown exclusively for her patients
and while she was pregnant with twins
she posted a tick tock video wearing her
labor gown that video went viral getting
more than two and a half million likes
and that led to the launch of her
business called Leela that was just out
of her home she launched the business
Caitlyn joins us now good morning
Caitlin very relevant because we got a
baby on the way my sister's about to
have a baby you just had one I had one a
year plus ago he's I've witnessed the
food
is a pro baby's having babies so Caitlyn
how did this all start accidentally how
was this an accident you know I designed
the labor gown because I wanted to offer
something to my clients and to my
patients but I never thought that I
would start a company from it and it
wasn't until I was in the hospital I was
on bed rest for a month and I was
wearing my own gowns every day and I
just made a video just for fun it wasn't
supposed to be anything about the Gown
it was just a you know a lighthearted
sort of thing and everybody wanted to
know more about it and everybody wanted
us to start a company so me and my
husband had to sit down and have a very
real conversation about whether or not
we wanted to do that because I mean that
video got millions of views and we got
160 000 followers overnight from it and
so you know it looked like a really
great opportunity but at the same time
it was also kind of scary because you
know at the time we were expecting twins
they were going to come any day or week
and we also had just gotten kicked out
of our rental home because at the heat
of covid you know the housing market was
really lucrative and our landlord wanted
to sell the house wow so we were kind of
I mean for lack of a better word like
homeless and we didn't have
um another home to move into we had a
trailer that we were going to move into
and so it was very much a leap of faith
to be like let's invest all of our
savings in starting this you made that
decision two days before your twins were
born so we had made the decision to set
a launch date that ended up being
actually the day before Oh my God our
Twins were born wow but that was because
they came two weeks early so it was It
was kind of crazy because I remember
being in the NICU and having my phone
just going off every because people were
like where can I get that gown yeah
people were buying them and we ended up
selling out 2 500 gallons in just two
hours so what do you think it is that
makes those gowns resonate so much with
women you know I think one of the things
was that a lot of women didn't know that
they had really any options that they
could go into the hospital and make any
choices for themselves they thought that
they just had to accept what was given
to them and I think that was the first
time a lot of people realized that they
could decide what I wanted to wear what
I wanted to bring what I wanted my birth
to look like I'm just astonished that
there had never been a conversation
with women about what that's what I was
going to ask I mean literally yes I just
like how could this not have been
addressed already so the fact that you
know it took you on Tick Tock to
revolutionize a very important and
intimate part of this process yeah it's
like why hadn't hospitals thought of
this already
you know I think that people had thought
of maybe the idea but personally I have
made some observations about you know
the way that mothers are sort of treated
you know when they transition into
motherhood I feel that sometimes you're
expected to sort of sacrifice your
identity your comfort your happiness in
order to be a good mom which of course
is flawed you know but that's kind of
our culture a little bit and so people
are just expected to accept what they're
given and not ask for more especially in
that context but in my opinion you know
giving birth is one of the most
significant yet vulnerable and
anxiety-inducing experiences that you
can go through and making it even just a
little bit better I think is really
important so Caitlin not only uh have
you started and founded this company uh
you are also United States Air Force
veteran you also hold the title of Mrs
United States 2020 and now you are
starting to be a midwife and you're
using Tick Tock social media to help
educate
folks about pregnancy birth and
documenting your own journey to becoming
a midwife why is that important for you
you know I'll be honest with you when I
had that viral video I had like I said
160 000 followers overnight I was not a
social media person I still don't really
feel entirely like a social media person
it wasn't really my thing but I kind of
felt that I had this message and I also
have this like captive audience now I
have people who are listening people who
are pregnant and I really wanted to
share a message about being able to
advocate for yourself having your voice
heard working with your provider team to
make Mutual decisions and it sort of
serves this overarching message of like
mothers matter too because I think
sometimes like I said we hyper fixate on
baby and we expect mothers to sacrifice
themselves and baby is so important of
course the health and safety of baby is
important yes mothers are important too
and they're not mutually exclusive you
can have it's important to have both
absolutely Caitlyn thank you so much